[Music]
[Applause]
when I was young I wanted to become a
painter I painted religiously but you
learn very quickly China in the west was
nothing
they say no you can't be a painter you
can't do anything except for restaurant
or laundry so he said I'm not going to
do a laundry I'm doing a restaurant
he had to invent a whole new persona
the name Mr Chow I wanted to create
respect respect for my country because
no one had called him Mr Chung Chinese
and low of low so I want to show them we
are the Sheikh of sheep this is theater
we're looking for Transcendence to a
higher place the restaurant was crazy
all the Hollywood is there
it was a safe place for a lot of people
but Mr Chow is a character created by
Him of the man who doesn't want people
to know who he really is
black and white with a stick piece my
father was completely an artist
revolutionized the Beijing Opera
he said to me wherever you go always
remember you are Chinese
the problem with racism it hurts if you
take away my glasses and take away my
Rose Royce I'm not good enough now
these paintings speak about turmoil
about tension but they're also very
joyous and free
and creativity is something that is very
important to him it's one of the things
that makes us human
most important thing about artists is
their job to be true to their time
[Music]
true to their dream and above all
true to themselves
[Music]
[Applause]